wir haben morgen vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht ein in
Karlsruhe eine gesetzesverhandlung da
geht es um die Frage ob ein Gesetz was
wir geschaffen haben 2021 Bestand haben
wird ob es verfassungswesen ist oder
nicht wir haben gesagt wenn einem Mörder
die Tat nachgewiesen werden kann nachdem
er schon freigesprochen wurde dann wäre
es schreiendes Unrecht wenn er für
diesen Nachweis nicht verurteilt werden
kann und da sind wir gespannt ob das
Bundesverfassungsgericht uns recht gibt
oder ob das fassungsgericht den Gegnern
zuneigt die behaupten wenn einmal eine
Entscheidung gefallen ist dann muss sie
erst Rechtssicherheitsgründen bestehen
wir meinen es wäre scheint es Unrecht
wenn ein Mörder nicht werden mit
reinnehmen gibt es da jetzt ein ganz
konkreten Fall
der Kläger ist eine Betroffene der
eines Mordes verdächtigt wurde dann aber
freigesprochen wurde kurz darauf aber
wurde anhand von dNA Spuren festgestellt
dass er doch der Täter sein muss und in
solchen Fällen meinen wir bei
unversehrbaren taten das ist wichtig
nicht bei einfachen Delikten sondern bei
unverlebaren Taten da meinen wir dass
die Rechtssicherheit durchbrochen werden
sollte damit ein Mörder am Ende doch
noch bestraft wird das klingt nach
Gerechtigkeit diese suchen die Frage
stellt sich nur her schubiles viele
Gerichte sind derzeit schon am Rande der
das Wahnsinns muss man fast sagen
Einfällen die Sie bearbeiten an
Bürokratie von denen sie stehen halten
sie das dann für umsetzbar
entbindet Sie nicht von der Pflicht für
Gerechtigkeit zu sorgen was mich
eigentlich wundert ist dass ich auch gar
nicht wusste das gebe ich jetzt ganz
offen zu ich hätte gedacht dass ein Fall
sowieso wieder aufgeräumt wird wenn es
eine neue Beweislage gibt nein sie haben
uns jetzt belehrt dass das nicht der
Fall ist es gibt solche Fälle wenn etwa
ein wenn sich herausstellt dass ein
gelogen hat dann gibt es heute schon in
engen begrenzten
ausmaßmöglichkeiten einer Wiederaufnahme
zu Ungunsten eines Freigesprochenen aber
nicht die Konstellation die wir im Auge
haben das ist in Deutschland so oder
überall weil ich höre zum Ausland oder
aus dem USA ja nach 40 Jahren wurde also
jemand für unschuldig erklärt weil es
neue Beweise gab
etwa in England haben sie die Regelung
die wir im deutschen jetzt auch haben
schon seit längerem die ein
Zusatzprotokoll der Europäischen
Menschenrechtskonvention sieht sowas vor
also wir haben da das Rad nicht neu
erfunden das heißt also jetzt es gibt
eine neue Beweislage ich wiederhole
jetzt noch mal ein ein schlagenden
Beweis oder der Richter entscheidet ja
das ist der Beweis dann wird das stand
dNA Spuren neuer Technik jetzt Spuren
dann wird das Verfahren neu aufgerollt
und dann kann es ein gegenteiliges
Urteil geben also erst Freispruch dann
genau bei unverberater
nicht eins sind sie sich bei diesem
Thema gesagt als konstruktive Opposition
im Bundestag und der Stützen wir das was
sinnvoll ist das ist leider im Moment
nicht so viel aber das ist ein
sinnvoller Vorschlag und ich glaube auch
da müsste der Kollege Fechner eher die
Kämpfe innerhalb der Ampelkoalition
wieder führen an der Union wird sowas
sinnvolles nicht scheitern ach so da
gibt es da internen Probleme in ihrer
Polizisten das Gesetz ist beschlossen
über seine Verfassungsmäßigkeit wird
morgen in Karlsruhe von den
bundesverfassungsstelle
also so eindeutig ist das nicht das
hatte SPD klargestellt nein
also jetzt geht's ja nur noch um das
Verfassungsgericht genau aber was ich
mich frage ist es gibt ja alles
viel zu gut also ich frage mich immer
als ein guter Mensch wo ist der Haken
oder vielleicht anders gefragt warum
nicht viel früher
also dieses Gesetz aber lieber öfter
Haken auf die 90er Jahre zurück da gab
es die ersten Initiativen und ist dann
lange beraten worden auch in der Goku wo
wir es dann letztendlich beschlossen
haben die Gegner sagen die
Rechtssicherheit ist ein zu hohes Gut
als dass wir davon abweichen dürfen auch
der Rechtsfrieden genau wenn einmal ein
Freispruch erfolgt ist dann muss der
auch gelten wir meinen in eng begrenzten
Ausnahmen bei den äh unversehrbaren
Taten wie Mord und Völkermord da ist es
Angebot der recht Gerechtigkeit wenn die
Tat nachgewiesen werden kann also nicht
einfach ins Blaue hinein noch mal
untersuchen sondern es muss ein Partner
weil es geben dann meinen wir das
einfach den gibt es doch aber eigentlich
immer nur wenn ein Verfahren neu
aufgerollt wird oder so Beweisstück
fällt ja nicht von Himmel also wie wie
ist die Praxis in dem die
Staatsanwaltschaft den Sachverhalt so
ermittelt dass sie davon ausgeht dass
durch neu Beweismittel die Tat auf jeden
Fall nachgewiesen werden Punkte genau ja
also muss ein bisschen auch vom Himmel
fallen ja vielleicht
intensiv in diesem Beispielsfall der
jetzt morgen zur Debatte steht da ging
es darum dass die auswertungstechnik der
DNA-Spuren in Zeitpunkt des ersten
Prozesses noch nie so ausgereift war
dass man den Tag Nachweis erbringen
konnte und durch die Verbesserung der
Technik hat man es später hinbekommen
wie viele Fälle werden da dann neue
aufgerollt haben sie da irgendwelche
aber den ein oder anderen Fall wird es
gehen wird es geben und dann vielleicht
auch Gerechtigkeit für Menschen die
vielleicht schon Jahrzehnte lang drauf
war